right so what you don't want to do is
you don't want to come high that seems
to be quite a normal thing
the level it's on is the level you do it
at
the level it's on
is the level you do it at
all right I don't want you to do the
women again I'm just trying to show you
some points here
to engage in is not there it's
controlled by this having this hip so
I'm gonna this hand will turn as this
hip turns and I've got to get it I can't
go a bit there a bit there it's got to
be like a gear wheel
all right it's got to be like a gear
wheel
cheer Nagi
color guys so the things you can't see
I'm trying to tell you
so this is in line with this so This
draws it might not be able to draw in
much I'm not gonna have a lot but but
look just a little draw because I need
him just like sansi John said you need
okay to be in a position
[Music]
see it's getting worse the timing
so you're over the years over the years
like you said it's it's working on
things so that you start to understand
at every any level
that oh I need to work on them
so you've got a Roman Aggie if you want
it
I'd like you to do perhaps a sheer Naggy
I'd like you to do a counter guys inside
they both have the drawer
even this one
doesn't leave in there it has the drawer
from the beginning the very very
beginning
the very beginning it has the draw as a
draw at the very beginning
all right so you've got them two and the
other one is you have the drawer and you
know thanks
because that drawer gives you the energy
to shoot in
okay so you've got three techniques